mathieu dans sa besace je crois que l'on
peut dire dans sanaa sa bonté excessive
et ce à son honnêteté légendaire regard
lino et commence à dire qu'est ce qu'il
est beau cet enfant il est magnifique il
est gentil pour la syrie rachète -
documentaire disney il
il est dans son truc ce vol et la syrie
c'est là que c'est vrai que matthew tu
m'a blessée parce que lino est un ami
avant tout au moment où vous êtes parti
dans l'ascenseur il s'est tourné vers
moi et il a dit je cite cet enfant est
exécrable je ne le supporte pas
je suis c'est juste à ça sa marraine
pour lui on s'échange des des barres de
chocolat tu m'as vu faire j'ai des
témoins j'ai été très simple demain ou
après demain je pense que demain mon
fils yamaha vous répondre oui mais en
direct